-Hello, everyone, and
welcome back to the attic.
I never, ever anticipated
that I'd be doing my show
not in a television studio
but in quiet solitude
in my attic,
slowly descending
into an ever-deepening chasm
of infinite madness.
But all things considered,
I really have grown to like it.
You know,
there's a magical quality
to this attic,
as evidenced by the fact
that my beloved copy
of "The Thorn Birds"
has multiplied and mutated into
anagrams of itself,
unpublished sequels,
similar-sounding titles.
and even other literary classics
with a "Thorn Bird" twist.
And let's be clear --
that's magic.
That's not something I'm doing,
because it would be
a colossal waste of time.
The door behind me
has provided entry
to not only wasps and firemen
but Academy Award nominee
Ethan Hawke,
leading some to ask, "Seth,
have you ever thought
of going through that door?"
And, yeah, the door does speak
and beckon for my entry,
but, I assure you, I have
no interest in finding out
where it leads,
and I certainly will not
be lured by its siren call.
And speaking of
ignoring things, -- segue --
the President has decided
to inhabit
an alternate reality
where the coronavirus pandemic
just doesn't exist,
even as the U.S.
sets a single-day record
for new cases.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ "A Closer Look"
theme music plays ]
An undeniable lesson
of the Trump era has been
that one of our two major
political parties
is filled with
mentally unwell weirdos.
Yesterday, for example,
at hearing
on Attorney General Bill Barr's
various abuses of power,
GOP Congressman Louie Gohmert
tried to drown out
a witness's testimony
by banging the table,
and he wouldn't stop.
[ Tapping ]
-This conduct in particular
gives cause for great concern
about what Barr may do next.
Just one -- one --
another 30 seconds.
In closing, it needs to be said
that Bill Barr
does regularly lie
in ways that impact
official action.
Along with his continuing
media project
to make Americans believe
that the FBI conspired
against Donald Trump...
-The witness will continue.
[ Tapping continues ]
-Can I have one more sentence?
-By all means.
-Okay.
[ Tapping continues ]
But, to me,
Barr's crowning dishonesty
is the portrait of
Edward Levy that --
-Mr. Chairman, I would ask
that the sergeant-at-arms
be called upon to stop
the disruption of this meeting.
[ Tapping continues ]
I can't hear this witness.
This is
a very important witness.
-Yeah, well, he's
well beyond the time.
-The Chair has the authority --
-If there are no rules about --
There's no rules
about when you can make noise.
-Ah, well-played, sir.
There aren't any rules
about when you can make noise.
And what a good point
for a 66-year-old man to make.
You know, there's
also not a rule
saying you can't interrupt
a witness' testimony
by streaking across
the House floor
in a giant foam cowboy hat.
You go, 'Mert! [Gohmert]
If he's gonna be
this irritating,
can we at least get him
a Hector Salamanca bell?
I mean, they do have
the same haircut.
That knockapalooza really is
one of the most childish things
I've ever seen in Congress,
and this is a place
where senators have brought
snowballs onto the Senate floor,
read "Green Eggs and Ham,"
and printed out a giant poster
of Michael Cohen's face
that said,
"Liar, liar, pants on fire!"
Congress is like some sort of
Montessori daycare
where, for 40 grand a year,
your child is supervised
by other children.
"We like to think of it
not as a daycare
but as a community.
Good job with the
knife-juggling, Ashley.
Be who you are.
Oh, God.
Oh, that's a -- that's a lot of
blood over there."
So, that's what a Republican
member of Congress was doing
on the day when the U.S. set
a new single-day record
for coronavirus infections.
And what about the President?
He was tweeting about --
you guessed it -- lobsters.
Cool. So, if you're one of
the 40 million people
who lost their job
during the pandemic,
and had to wait in line
for unemployment,
just jump in a boat
and catch some lobster.
Instead of a second stimulus
check in the mail,
every American is gonna get
a fishing net
and a pair of rubber boots.
But you got to be suspicious
when Trump tweets
a bunch of nice things
about your industry
out of nowhere.
It's like getting flowers
from your husband
on a regular Tuesday morning.
Your first thought has to be,
"What did you do?"
Well, it won't surprise you
to learn
that Trump is lying
about this, too.
And when you can lie
about lobster,
the sky is the limit.
Next, he's gonna tweet...
In reality,
lobster exports plunged
after Trump took office,
thanks to his trade war.
Of course Trump is lying.
If he really thought
he'd made lobstering
so profitable,
he'd be going from
restaurant to restaurant,
plunging his hands
into lobster tanks,
trying to steal
as many as he could.
"Damn you, you son of a bitch.
Keep those pincers away from me.
This lobster is Antifa."
So, a Republican Congressman
was banging on tables,
and the president was lying
about lobster
as the U.S.
was setting a new record
for coronavirus infections,
five months after
our first official case.
Remember, at the beginning
of this outbreak,
when you heard the phrase
"flatten the curve"
over and over again,
like you were watching
a Billy Blanks workout video?
"Come on, everyone,
two knee raises
into a side kick.
Tae Bo is all about
flattening those curves!"
That's why we all
stayed in our homes,
watching "Maury,"
and drinking cereal
straight out of the bowl,
in our sweatpants
for three months.
The point was to get cases and
hospitalizations
down to a manageable level and
to limit community transmission
so we could get
a rigorous system
of testing and contact tracing
in place
that would allow us
to safely get back
to some semblance of normalcy.
Instead, the president
has squandered all of that,
complained that testing
makes him look bad,
and called on his government
to slow testing down.
And now his administration
is following through,
cutting funding to testing sites
as the outbreak reaches
its worst levels yet.
-There's a new plan
at the White House
for how to deal with
coronavirus testing
at the federal level
in states across the country.
Geoff Bennett reporting
that the Trump administration
is planning to end
its funding and support
for coronavirus testing sites at
the end of this month.
That is, on June 30th.
-That's right, they're cutting
federal funding
for community testing sites now,
as the outbreak hits a new peak.
That's like a pilot turning off
the "seat belt" sign
after they graze a mountain.
"Don't worry, folks, we just
nicked one of the Rockies.
Feel free to stretch your legs,
and don't look out the window.
I assure you that
at least half of our wings
are still attached
to the plane."
At what point can we say
Trump is actively putting people
in harm's way?
He holds indoor rallies,
refuses to wear a mask,
and wants to cut back
on testing.
Soon, he's gonna start going
door-to-door,
coughing on people
and licking their doorknobs.
Just yesterday, it was reported
that dozens of Secret Service
officers and agents
were told to self-quarantine
after Trump's Tulsa rally.
Trump is a one-man
superspreader.
He is the "Ozark" swimming pool
of human beings.
That's why his Secret Service
code name is Typhoid Gary.
"Typhoon Gary is on the move.
Well, less of a move.
It's more of a lumber."
Trump has said repeatedly,
since the day this all started,
that he dislikes testing,
because it makes him look bad.
And even after his staff tried
to claim he was joking,
he corrected them
and said he was serious
about slowing down testing.
-I don't kid.
By having more tests,
we find more cases.
Therefore, we test, we're
gonna have more cases.
By having more cases,
it sounds bad.
-It sounds bad because it's bad.
Look, man, if you don't like
the sound a smoke alarm makes,
stop putting giant balls
of aluminum foil
in the microwave.
"But I need to
keep my foil ball warm."
If we stop testing for cases,
that doesn't mean
the cases aren't there.
That just means
we don't know about them.
You can go into
a roadside motel room
without a black light,
but it doesn't mean the linens
are springtime fresh.
So now our curve
is headed back up
after months of Americans
making tremendous sacrifices
to try to flatten it.
Meanwhile, there are lots of
other countries that really did
flatten their curves.
Just look at
the European Union
or the dozens of countries
that have successfully
suppressed their outbreaks.
-The first group
is the countries
that appear to have
successfully suppressed
transmission of the disease.
That curve has come
all the way down
so that they are barely
registering any new cases.
We have Andorra, Australia,
Austria, Bhutan, Cambodia,
China, Croatia, Cuba, Djibouti,
Estonia, Greece, Iceland,
Jamaica, Jordan, Kosovo, Latvia,
Lebanon, Liechtenstein,
Lithuania, Luxembourg, Malta,
Mauritius, Monaco, Montenegro,
New Zealand, Slovakia, Slovenia,
South Korea, Taiwan, Thailand,
Tunisia, and finally Vietnam.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Slow down.
Hey, honey, what would you think
about moving to Mauritius?
You always said
you like the sand.
You like the sand, honey.
Sounds like a list of countries
Jay Leno would ask
a bunch of spring breakers
to find on a map.
"Un, where's, uh, Djibouti?"
"Right here, baby!
There's Djibouti."
We even did worse than Iceland,
a country that has
a penis museum
and where -- and this is true --
people still believe in elves.
The only mythical creatures
we have are Pasta Goblins.
"Finish your rotini, Anthony,
or the Pasta Goblin
will come and steal your neck."
Yeah, that is a callback to
yesterday's "Closer Look."
I mean, I'm guessing
it's the same people
who watch every night, right?
Anyway, if this is your first
look," welcome aboard.
We used have to have
an audience.
America could have been
like one those countries.
In fact, some of them
have been able
to restore the cultural markers
of normalcy we all crave,
like live sports,
with fans in attendance.
-This is a welcome sight
for sports fans.
No social distancing
and no masks,
as 43,000 fans
were in the stadium
for a rugby match
in New Zealand.
The country had
remarkable success
eliminating the coronavirus.
This weekend's match
marked a big milestone.
No new cases of the virus
have been reported
in more than three weeks.
-New Zealand had fans in
attendance at a rugby match.
Meanwhile, the NBA is planning
on trapping its players
at Disney World like
a family stuck
on a three-hour line
for Space Mountain.
"I told you we shouldn't have
wasted a FastPass
on Journey Into Imagination,
Lebron.
I told you."
We could have been
like New Zealand.
They're going to
live sporting events
and eating nachos in the sun,
while we're stuck here
with President Lobster,
trekking to Trader Joe's
every two weeks
in a beekeeper's suit
stuffed with Clorox wipes.
"If I don't make it back, don't
forget, microwave the mail."
Because our outbreak
is actually getting worse.
We just set a new record,
and the peak is now higher
than it was back in April,
despite the fact
that Trump and his team
repeatedly told us
they had succeeded
in flattening the curve.
-We've flattened the curve
and really made
tremendous progress.
-I'm proud to report to you,
as the head of
the White House
Coronavirus Task Force,
we slowed the spread,
we flattened the curve.
-I think you'll see, by June,
a lot of the country
should be back to normal,
and the hope is
that, by July, the country is
really rocking again.
-Is there anything less
"rocking"
than hearing Jared Kushner
say "rocking?"
If James Hetfield said,
"Are you ready to rock?"
and then Jared Kushner
came onstage,
fans would tear the place
to the ground.
What even constitutes
rocking for Kushner?
A second glass of rosé
on the catamaran?
Let's just face facts.
Jared is Steff
from "Pretty in Pink,"
with worse hair.
Because, Steff,
you were a real a-hole.
But with hair like that,
I just can't stay mad.
Wait, would I like Kushner
if he had Steff hair?
No! Take it away.
And that's a second callback
to yesterday's "Closer Look"
Trump has decided to just ignore
and, even worse,
actively cover up
a national catastrophe
that is only getting worse,
despite months of sacrifices
by Americans who endured
tremendous pain.
There's no way to conclude
anything other than the fact
that the president is actively
putting Americans in harm's way
to serve his own narrow
political agenda.
It's true, even though...
-It sounds bad.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
Papa.
[ "A Closer Look"
theme music plays ]
As New York works hard
to open under phase 2,
remember that we're still
a city in crisis,
and City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands.
We love you.